award-winning broadcaster play-by-play
announcer for the NHL on NBC game seven
tonight
it's the Leafs against the Bruins do you
have a different mindset doc first of
all good morning do you have a different
mindset as far as a play-by-play man
going into a game seven as opposed to a
game one yes our executive producer
always says that game sevens we have to
not do a lot of inside stuff like we do
on how a series evolved and how it goes
on but basically taken all the people
who will watch a game seven who might
not watch a game four or five game
sevens are a magnet they attract people
because of the do-or-die nature of it
and so for that reason we try to be more
generic and also maybe not talk as much
when play stops because there is a
built-in drama that that the crowd
brings and that waiting for a faceoff
brings the heroes in Game seven you just
cannot predict our star players only
play twenty minutes out of 60 they're on
the bench
two-thirds of the time in our sport and
eighteen guys dress and two goaltenders
and everybody plays except maybe the
backup goaltender and so for that reason
Game seven heroes can come from anywhere
Wayne Gretzky and Mario Lemieux and
Brett Hall have all had winning goals in
game sevens but so have Nino
Niederreiter and Nicolai warships and
Porthos - you just don't know that's the
fun part of game sevens and so I guess
the thing is we just try to not we try
to take in everybody and not talk too
much about X's and O's but more about
what gladiators these guys are what a
great sport it is and try to be as
generic as possible so that people that
don't watch it all the time can enjoy it
too
greatest Game seven you've been a part
of Wow
that is a tough one there have been a
lot of tremendous ones and and that I
know that sounds like a cop-out but boy
I think probably the one that comes to
mind because I'm sitting in Boston was
the conference final between Tampa Bay
and Boston
Dwayne Roloson was probably in his 40s
playing goal and Tim Thomas was in it
wasn't his glory years here with Boston
and the winner would go on to the
Stanley Cup Final and play Vancouver and
it was a one nothing game that's one
that stands out in my mind because it
wouldn't recent and it was here in
Boston but NBC asked me to count these
up and tonight will be the 42nd Wow
toughest name you still have problems
with oh I don't know well he retired
who's that teen often I don't know why
it was so hard but a colleague named
bill Clemente got me out of it it it
shouldn't be that hard it's only three
syllables but it was putting the Chi in
the North and all of that together and
of course when it when it happens on the
ice and then they move the puck fast it
kept coming out and Mt mauve and he said
same M naught M naught M naught and and
I guess that was Bill is a former actor
and so he had all of these tricks and he
taught me how to do that there's so many
of those great names like Nikolai Hobbie
bulan and but there but there is a
rhythm of flow to them once you get it
down then it's okay
like Ilkeston Asolo like they're just
you know Petrus Creek oh yeah they're
just so many of those great names well
these are all the names I remember from
doing highlights on SportsCenter oh yes
and and the good thing is that when they
when you get several of them on the same
team and you you uh you rattled off some
some names from the Western Conference
there or from what used to be what the
Campbell conference I guess it was we
used to have guys come to the all-star
game and didn't know what which team
they were on because because the
conference's were names at that time one
thing Gary Bettman did for us was make
it east and west but yes they would have
all those names that would come together
and
and all of a sudden you would have them
popping up in a series that that you
were doing if you hadn't done that team
all year it would seem sort of strange
but you would kind of envision sometimes
your boss sitting down in the stands
with a small bag of cash in his hand and
if you studied hard and got the names
and numbers right at the end of a series
he would hand you two back I guess that
was one of the motivators and also the
other side of it was you you really took
pride in wanting to do the job right
and that was part of doing it right and
you found that Sports Center I mean
people know if you're if you're
pronouncing the names right
the real confusing part was when usually
it happens with one of the guys from
Europe they would change the
pronunciation or they would say they
didn't care and then one of the PR
departments would say he's saying it
differently now and we have had that
recently Connor sherry with Pittsburgh
you know as said that his uncle like the
way that he said his name more recently
than when he first came into the league
so it's different now and there was a
guy named Teemu Selanne who came into
the league in his rookie year changed it
and it was a lot easier for people in
Winnipeg to say Salani and so he agreed
and so the Finnish way of saying it
changed to the way that all of us
anglicized it wouldn't you if your
Miroslav shirt and just said Satan right
fun with that name I remember that I
remember watching some of the Devils
like he had to play for the Devils right
I mean he's sure yeah it made a lot of
sense if he would I remember four years
ago when I was visiting you guys and one
thing that I learned you know you always
have the roundtable on what did you
learn today yes the one thing I learned
that day is that Seton likes to go glove
side low on McLovin of course remember
that sequence what a tremendous move he
made that day it was I don't know if
you've had a hockey showdown I know you
shoot POW shots a lot and you do a lot
of outside
that shooting and so forth there that
was that was noteworthy that day and I
don't know if he's ever put on the gear
sense but McLovin has something to show
because usually I go peanut butter shelf
on McLovin he's doc Emmerich he's got
Game seven coming up tonight 7:30
Eastern it'll be the Leafs in the Bruins
do you want to do like a loud building
or a quiet building to do your job
Oh loud loud and raucous and you know
we've got we've got an anthem singer
that has said that he's in his
retirement year and so this potentially
could be his last for an a-rank already
started in the mid seventies here and he
does the fist pumps after the anthem the
building is is just wacky here in Boston
and that it's a it's a genuine wackiness
there's nothing manufactured about it
they care about their Bruins and so
it'll be raucous and and the teams will
either come out nervous and tentative at
the very beginning because that does
happen in game sevens or it may just it
may just be nothing but listening to the
boards and the glass in the first five
minutes because there may be lots of
pounding it'll be fun whatever it is do
you get recognized by your voice like if
you're at a restaurant or calling down
for room service or the front desk or
anything today sometimes yes sometimes
it is flattering and it's it's nice when
people recognize you like that and
occasionally I get stopped you know I'll
miss it when it doesn't happen anymore I
remember that time when there was
someone on Johnny Carson's old show and
he said that anybody that's involved in
in the public eye there is that for
example he used John Wayne as an example
who is John Wayne get me John Wayne get
me a John Wayne type who is John Wayne
and it happens with everybody in the
public eye and when they say who is Mike
Emmerich I'll miss that whole time
because I do enjoy it when people come
up and want to take a picture or they
want me to sign something that's the fun
part of doing this too but to me the fun
part is preparing and
getting in free and getting a good seat
for the game and getting to be around
athletes that also really enjoy their
part in the hockey world before I let
you go can you explain to us to this
audience of the Vegas story you know
because I mean it's the Golden Knights
have been that that's been the feel-good
story how did it happen well the easy
answer is that they got some favorable
rules for the expansion draft but they
made the best of them but that's real
simplicity the fact that they made good
choices but that when these guys came
together they came together with a
purpose that went to the second power
and that they have delivered and over
over compensated for what people's
expectations were all year and then
those of us who are a little skeptical
about the fact they had no adversity
that they had to overcome all year and
they went into the first round against a
big bulky bunch of Los Angeles Kings and
we thought okay this may be the first
visit of adversity they're going to have
and what did they do one of the best
goaltenders Jonathan Quick gave up seven
goals in four games and lost all four
because Marc Andre flurry only gave up
three goals total in four games and now
they're going to face the San Jose
Sharks and these guys are impressive and
as of yesterday some of the lower bowl
tickets were going for 4,000 a piece out
on the street well there is a mania
about seeing these guys play and God
bless them they've they've done it all
hockey wise in the best way possible
they've hired great announcers to
deliver their games they've done things
right and it's all worked out for them
like it hasn't for any other expansion
team in the history of sports and this
thing just keeps snowballing and
evolving and good for them say hello to
Millberry and Pierre and have fun as
always doc always great to catch up with
you a pleasure it sure is a lot of fun
talking to you again
thanks for all your help through these
years document NHL play by play
Beeman NBC SN for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]